[MUSIC PLAYING]
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: I want
to move on a little bit
towards another
challenge that I hear
from agencies time
and time again,
which is about recruitment
growth and retention.
So it's really tricky to
acquire very good talent
into a company.
And it's even trickier,
in many respects,
to keep that talent that.
I'd say the turnover
rate in agencies
as a whole tends to
be a little bit higher
than many other organizations.
So, what is it that you
do to maximize retention
within your company?
JEFF NAMNUM: So, I don't
want anybody to throw up,
but we don't really have
many problems with retention.
In fairness, we're probably
smaller than a lot of you all.
But the reason that we don't--
and I'm talking maybe three
folks in the last three
years that we have lost.
There's a few factors to that.
One, we cheat, right?
We cheat on
recruitment big time.
Kevin, my partner, was either
dumb enough or brilliant enough
to be one of the founders of
the Android Meetup in New York
City, which is now--
under the guidance
of our wonderful, wonderful,
brilliant Olivia--
something over 3,500 members.
We do run the
Droidcon in New York,
and we have our hand in most
of the Droidcons in America,
in one way or another.
We encourage our
folks to go speak.
We sometimes force
our folks to speak.
Part of coming to
Touchlab is you're
at the center of that little
developer and design world,
and people are
going to know you,
if you want them to know you.
So we attract a very
specific kind of folk,
but that's just our
way of cheating, right?
Novoda did something
very similar, right?
Knowing the boys over
there, Kevin and Carl
did an unbelievable
job of doing just
about the same damn thing in
parallel, in another country.
And that thing, whatever
that thing is, I think
is crucial, right?
Kevin and I, we speak a lot.
We're press hogs.
And some people dig that.
Plus, we have a
lot of fun, right?
We have a really
good time internally.
And it has paid off.
I remember putting up our ad
for our very first designer,
our very first
in-house designer.
And we got a reply the
same day from possibly one
of the best known,
outside of Google, Android
first designers.
It was great, right?
But that's all because we cheat.
I think if you're--
no offense, right?
Agency life is hard.
If you're just
doing the same thing
that everybody else
is doing, you're not
getting who you really want.
RYAN BATEMAN: Yeah, I
think that's good advice.
PRADEEP NALLURI: Yeah.
RYAN BATEMAN: Cheating
as a way to get ahead.
Yeah, I would say getting
out into the community,
automatically you
self-select the people who
want to be engaged in
the technology are then
part of your meetup group,
or-- yeah, people who are just
engaged with technology.
And then in terms of
retention, if you then
recognize that the
people you've hired
are driven by a passion
for this technology,
again, that's
another way to cheat.
Give them a conference budget.
Help them plot a career path.
Make sure there is education to
help them build as developers
or designers or proj managers.
And, yeah, it's all cheating.
But you're just building
really, really great people
to work with.
JEFF NAMNUM: And you
don't have to start
a meetup like your guys
did and like we did.
You don't have to start one.
You can just get
involved in one, right?
We didn't start the iOS meetups.
You get involved in community.
RYAN BATEMAN: That's
better than cheating.
JEFF NAMNUM:
Community is so much
a nicer word than cheating.
Community.
It's loving.
Loving and beautiful.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: Pradeep,
anything to add to that?
PRADEEP NALLURI: These guys
answered the holy grail, right?
Kidding.
But I think we are in
the business of selling
our people's time and efforts.
We should have a
people-first approach policy.
There's a lot of jobs
for talented people.
Why do they have to work
with your agency, right?
That's something
you need to think
about every day, every
night before you go to bed.
Enlisting people, give
them meaningful work,
challenging work.
Keep talking about how the
work they're going to do
is going to help the
community or the society.
I think that's one thing.
Keep paying for their learnings,
and they're unstoppable.
In fact, we have [? Mustafa, ?]
[? Fanisha, ?] [INAUDIBLE],
they're with the company
for last five years.
They started out as interns.
Our retention program is really,
really working well for us.
They come through-- our
primary source of recruitment
is by internship.
Then we put them through
something called Mutual Mobile
Academy.
Jay's here.
I think he can talk about it.
Our senior leaders
in the company
actually conduct these classes.
They do this training
program, training classes.
So having in-house Academy,
and engineering leaders
conducting those courses for
the interns, and making sure
they're always working
on exciting stuff
and not just doing what
other agencies are doing--
if you're working
on emerging tech
it actually helps, because
they're constantly learning.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: Excellent.
But have you used any
of the Udacity content?
So there's professional
nanodegrees that are available,
and some companies have
been doing study jams
where you actually bring
together a number of developers
to learn at the same
pace, at the same time.
And that motivates
one another to go
through the program
at the same time
and actually, ideally, get
certified at the end of this.
Is that something
you've adopted?
PRADEEP NALLURI: No, we plan
to actually use nanodegree
for our intern program.
That's a prerequisite.
Once you join, you need to get
certified within two months.
Otherwise, you're
out of the company,
out of the internship program.
I think the senior
engineering team actually
did the advanced
courses in Udacity,
and they have benefited
a lot from it.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: Excellent.
So what are the
benefits you've seen?
Has that been more about
speaking a common language?
Or uniting--
PRADEEP NALLURI: It's
actually when our engineers
and when our developers,
designers, work on their craft,
there's no internal benefit.
But when they actually
speak to the client,
it actually shows in the
work and the kind of product
we ship.
So that's the benefit we have.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: Yeah.
PRADEEP NALLURI:
The quality products
you see in the app store,
that's because of the training
and the hard work these
guys do behind the scene.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: Excellent.
Anything to add to that
in terms of the training
that you run internally?
RYAN BATEMAN: Yeah, we have
a very similar program.
We run something called
Novoda University, where,
if you join the company, you
are put on to the training
program for a few months.
You get time set aside to read
up on kind of common texts.
We're now also integrating
Udacity courses.
And the other kind of added
benefit we try and push
a little bit is we try and
get people on these courses
to give what we
call hack intels.
So they talk about what
they've been learning.
And it's a chance to kind of
push them a little bit, maybe,
to talk to everyone else.
So that's just a quick, kind
of 15-minute talk through.
And then out of that
as well, it gives them
kind of a basis for speaking
technically to other people,
if they don't have that already.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: And, Jeff,
what about Touchlab University?
The university
thing seems to be--
JEFF NAMNUM: Touchlab University
was almost a very different
thing.
So we don't have a formalized
program officially.
Everybody goes through a thing.
We don't have a name for it.
We don't, at this
point, use Udacity.
We are in New York.
Since we're all
there, we're somewhat
fortunate in that
there is consistently
something happening, right?
So our folks learn
from one another.
They learn, quite frankly--
not to give him a big head--
but a lot from Kevin.
And there's a lot of
one-on-one time with him.
And then we have
them go teach, right?
We were very
fortunate to-- Kevin
helped develop a program over
at C4Q, Coalition for Queens,
which helps under-represented
folks learn development.
We at least had a
hand in reviewing GAs.
A General Assembly in America
has the official Android
course, in-person course.
We had a hand in reviewing that.
We have folks who
go out and mentor
different young
developer groups.
There's a lot to learn in
the projects that we do,
because we tend not to do the
same thing twice very often.
But we do think that
getting out and teaching,
and teaching one another,
also reinforces quite a bit.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: So actually,
the question I've got as well
is we're seeing quite a strong
debate between native and web,
and what's the role
between the two,
and whether you can just
get away with a web client
when the right time
is to go native.
Do you have any strong
feelings about that?
So I'm going to ask you
last, because actually I
think-- actually I'll ask
you first on this one,
because you'll sit very clearly
on one side of the equation,
I suspect.
RYAN BATEMAN: Yeah, I mean yes.
Yes and no.
I think there are
certainly occasions
where hybrid applications
or web applications are
a good solution.
I don't think it's as often as
certain companies would like.
And from a budget
perspective, it
can't always make more sense.
Native development does
inherently take longer.
But certainly for Novoda, we're
very much focused on quality,
and we're very much focused
on quality of experience
from a user perspective.
And I'd love to see
someone challenge it,
but I've yet to see a web
application that could
meet a good native experience.
JEFF NAMNUM: Yes,
yes, yes, and yes.
So, yeah, Kevin and I
have this discussion.
And there are always
situations where
a hybrid-- that's a nice name--
a hybrid application makes
sense.
And it's generally
where, quite frankly,
the user has no option, right?
It's an educational app.
There's a specific
budget requirement.
And what's the
student going to do?
Say, I really don't
like this, teacher?
So they have no option.
It doesn't matter what their
experience is, because you
don't care, as an organization.
Sometimes internal
corporate apps
are forced down the throats
for employees in the same way.
As you can see, I'm
not a big huge fan.
So when the experience doesn't
matter, great option, right?
When you don't give a crap about
the person who's getting it?
Awesome.
I agree I've not
seen-- now that's not
to say I haven't seen really
great web applications
in native wrappers.
I have seen that.
I can think of a few shops
that do an awesome job at that.
Active Theory is
one I'm thinking of.
But those are damn
specific cases.
They're like games or
event-driven things.
The challenge with
native, both ways, right?
Because again, the platform is
increasingly, in my opinion,
increasingly going
to be less important.
I'm not going to say
that out loud, though.
The glass is what matters,
and getting to the glass
and delivering that
experience is what matters.
And the big
challenge with native
is you're building the same
crap twice very often, right?
All the logic, everything
underneath the hood,
is the same damn thing twice.
And as you're maintaining
it over the course of months
and years, you get
even copy/paste errors.
And those things have to be
tracked down, and that cost,
that's a real cost.
There are some good solutions.
There may be a much better
solution on the horizon,
and that's all I'll
say about that.
But it is the challenge.
But there is no
comparison to native
when it comes to quality.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD:
It's interesting you
say that in the context
of progressive web
apps like Flipkart, for
example, where you just
have a pure mobile web
experience that arguably
delivers a very
native-like experience
but purely using
web technologies
rather than, I'd say,
the hybrid web-view apps,
which is a slightly
different case.
JEFF NAMNUM: Yeah,
doing a thing, yeah.
PRADEEP NALLURI: We do have a
[INAUDIBLE] web team in Austin
in our office, and they
have shipped really, really
elegant products.
So we are agnostic
in this debate.
We apply what is the right
solution for the client.
And we have shipped web-views
inside a native container.
So we do what is
best for the client
or what is best for the product.
We don't want to take the
sides and get into this
because-- but there
are times when you want
an extremely good experience.
We recommend native.
Yeah, we are on the
side of the native.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD:
Another question I've got
is, have you
convinced-- I don't know
if you've stumbled
across this problem
where, maybe they come from
the iOS side, your customer,
or they come from
the Android side.
And they seem to believe
that one size fits all.
I think you're kind of nodding
and smiling going, oh, I've
never come across it before.
In that situation, have
you brought arguments
that actually worked with them,
to convince them that that's
not the right way forward?
And I know trust is an
important part of that.
We've talked about that
a little bit already.
Is there anything
else that you've
used to convince them
that actually they've
got to think a little bit
differently about this?
JEFF NAMNUM: Kevin and I have
two different little vignettes
that we're big fans
of in that situation.
And Kevin's is-- and
I'll tell it wrong,
and Kevin will correct it later.
Find Kevin later, and he will
tell this in the clever way.
The stepchild theory, right?
Android users are damn
tired of being the stepchild
with the hand-me-downs.
Here is your Instagram
app eight months later,
stripped down in functionality.
And you know what?
It looks just like an iOS
app and functions like one.
And it doesn't feel right
to people, and they hate it.
They hate it.
I tend to talk more about
the ratings spiral, right?
Android users, they're
going to be vocal.
And they're going to vote
with their thumbs, right?
They're going to give you
the lowest star rating.
And the second you dip below
4, really, but let's say 3.5,
people are thrilled
to give you 1s, right?
If you're above a 4,
then they're like, damn,
if I give this guy
a 1, it's like me.
It's all me.
But you're 3.5,
they're like, nope,
I'm thrilled to
just pile on the 1s.
And then it's just
[BUZZING SOUND].
And that comes from not
feeling an experience, right?
Now we tell those
little stories,
but then really and truly it
is that design-- design has
to be centered on
a user, and it has
to be educated by the context
of that user, in whatever that--
and the context shifts
in different situations.
But in the situation of mobile,
a very important context
is the platform that
they're used to.
And you would never,
ever have a designer
with no experience in
iOS design an iOS app,
unless you just
had money to burn
and didn't care about results.
And people relate to
that very quickly.
RYAN BATEMAN: I would
say a good-- yeah,
building on that, a good
kind of thing we push
is the [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, that's a great idea.
Cool.
So we take that
basis of the design.
We'll do just another
design for our own sake,
because we have our own opinion.
And then we'll do some
very basic user testing,
because we try and push
user research-based design.
And oh, look, surprise.
Oh, the iOS design doesn't
seem to work with the five
people we pulled in.
Oh, well, we're
going to have to go
with the Android
design that's much more
native to the platform.
And that's-- yeah,
it does depend.
I think that you can't
do that all the time.
But if all the arguments
fail, it's easier
just to pull in five random
people and say, yeah,
this is our expert witness.
PRADEEP NALLURI: In the past
we had issues with that.
But I think with the
material coming along,
our customers and clients
understand the value of design.
But it's still hand
me down, as you said.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
had phone problem.
They design primarily for iOS,
and when-- Android is always
second in thought and
always like product,
getting that Apple,
especially in North America.
That's when we get iOS
designs, our designers actually
go through it and completely
do the material for it
and implement it.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: Excellent.
I'm going to come
to a last question
now, because I know we're
running out of time.
But if you were going to give
one tip to the other agencies
here, something you
found useful internally
within your own
company, that you
found a way of doing things that
maybe is not hugely well-known
but has been really helpful for
you as a company, what would it
be?
RYAN BATEMAN: So off my head,
the one tip, the silver bullet,
I would say listen
to your developers.
If they feel like they're
building a bad app,
odds are pretty good they
are building a bad app.
Any agency, especially
in the beginning,
you take the work
that you can find,
and you build something
that's based on iOS.
And if you listen
to your developers,
they hate doing that, because
they know instinctively
they're building something they
don't believe in or care about.
And if you optimize for somebody
who's building something
that they believe is
a quality product,
then what you're
going to end up with
is probably a quality product.
PRADEEP NALLURI: I think the
digital landscape is vast.
And don't try to be jack of all.
Pick few [? a verticle ?]
specializations,
and be world class
at it is my advice.
JEFF NAMNUM: Say no.
Say no when you know
you should say no.
Stop saying yes when you
know you should say no.
You know you should
have said no.
You know that client is
the same damn client you
had three months ago, and he is
just as bad as that guy before.
Say no.
You know that decision is wrong.
It sucks, and it's terrifying,
especially when you're little
and you're starting, but say no.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: Excellent.
Well, thank you very
much to our panelists.
I mean, there's a ton
of different things
we could talk about, and
I'd like you to explore
some of these topics later.
It could be around
design, resource planning,
prototyping, interagency
collaboration, and continuing
these kind of
conversations afterwards.
What team structures do you use?
How do you operate
teams effectively?
How do you deal with pipeline
management, structures, roles,
thinking about the market?
All of these things are
fascinating to talk about
and hear these different
perspectives in the room.
So I'll just leave that with
you to think about, and thank
you very much to our panel.
Thank you Jeff,
Pradeep, and Ryan.
It's been fascinating.
Well done.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]